benoît biteau une dernière question le
coc vide a selon vous favorisez l'idée
d'une pac encore plus ambitieuse en
matière de protection de l'environnement
on a une petite idée de votre réponse au
contraire il faut produire à tout prix
pour nourrir les européens dans ce
contexte anxiogène faut déjà arrêter de
penser que produire à tout prix ses
produits avec des pesticides j'insiste
sur ce que j'ai dit quand des élus
continuent de dire on a besoin d'une
étude d'impact mais on a suffisamment de
données scientifiques qui nous font la
démonstration que l'agro écologie permet
de produire autant sans pesticides et
sans engrais de synthèse et ans et quand
on parle pour répondre à madame aguilar
quand on parle du revenu des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui on a aussi
suffisamment de données économiques qui
font la démonstration que ceux qui ont
renoncé aux pesticides
ceux qui pratiquent l'agroécologie sont
les agriculteurs qui s'en sortent le
mieux
et ils s'en sortiront d'autant mieux
qu'on arrêtera d'utiliser l'argent
public pour perfuser ceux qui utilisent
des pesticides pour accompagner ces
agriculteurs qui dans une rémunération
parce qu'ils rendent des services un
intérêt commun au climat à la santé à la
biodiversité et pour finir avec le co
vide effectivement le coc vide nous
donne un certain nombre d'enseignements
sur la fragilité de la souveraineté
alimentaire sur l'intérêt de la
biodiversité parce que la biodiversité
est un rempart
assez assez possible pandémie à ces
possibles zoonoses et donc ça doit nous
encourager encore plus vite à
accompagner cet agriculteur à cette
agriculture à rémunérer les agriculteurs
qui prennent soin de cet enjeux de
biodiversité pour éviter d'avoir des co
vite ça doit nous inviter mais arrêter
de subventionner des élevages
industriels qui sont des nids à pandémie
donc voilà dans une approche
[Musique]